we have a new person at the table hello
Hope Solo she made a name for herself as
one of the most accomplished soccer
goalkeepers in the world she helped the
u.s. women's team win the 2015 World Cup
and she played on three consecutive
Olympic teams solo to set records for
the most career shutouts and the longest
undefeated streak by a goalkeeper male
or female male or female thank you no
that's good drop the microphone Thanks
but she also made headlines for what
happened off the field in her years on
the u.s. national team solo spoke out
about coaching decisions she was
suspended for 30 days in 2015 and she
encouraged teammates to join her in a
federal complaint alleging wage
discrimination her time with the team
came to an explosive end in 2016 US
soccer terminated her contract after she
made negative comments about an opposing
team at the Rio Olympics Solo has now
launched a bid to lead the US Soccer
Federation she's running to be the
organization's
first female president and bring a
platform of change Hope Solo joins us
now hope good to see you again thank you
it's good to see you think about
everything and now you're running for
president of this organization what is
what are you running on what's your
platform well you have to understand
that for 20 years during my career I
fought for change within the system I
fought for gender equity I fought
against and justices and it we weren't
really getting anywhere so this became
kind of a natural step for me to really
really continue that fight to run for
president and to really get inside the
organization and force this change that
we've been fighting for 20 years to do
so it was really important for me and my
platform is really focused on youth
development u.s. soccer has 150 million
dollars in surplus funds and they don't
put it back to the youth of America and
so it's really become the sport here in
America that is dedicated to the rich
white kid and we are excluding so many
of potential great youth players so
they're saying you you were new and you
were not one of the rich white kids as
you point out in your platform that you
would have been one of the kids that
would have been excluded you say you
want to make it affordable in excess
what does that mean well u.s. soccer's
mission statement is to make soccer the
preeminent sport here in the United
States we can't do that unless we make
it accessible and affordable for every
young kid in America right now it's
business first over progress at the
heart of the Federation and we have to
go back to really making soccer a
beautiful culture here in America and in
order to do that we have to invite
people to play we cannot exclude them
what does that mean in practical terms
I'm a parent if I'm the suburb I have
time I have the money to buy all the
equipment is that what it is is it
getting fields where kids are or what
the cost for young kids are continuing
to grow it costs anywhere between 5,000
to 11,000 dollars per year for a young
kid in travel expenses - just for
registration fees and and most kids
can't afford it anymore
so it really it has to be addressed and
it doesn't happen anywhere in any other
country and all the rest of the world is
better at soccer so they are allowing
the young kids to play without having
these excessive fees hope you are
running to lead an organization that
terminated your contract do you have the
internal support to win I have a great
amount of support through the state
associations for youth soccer through
adult soccer there are a number of
different voting delegates it's not just
the board members at US Soccer it's not
just the you know the current leadership
within the Federation soccer is
important to a lot of people and a lot
of people have voting rights to this
election no I saw your support I watched
you when you gave your speech as to why
you wanted this job you had a lot of
support but you had some haters too that
said yep she's a great athlete but she's
not exactly a good a great role model
what do you say to that that people talk
about what's happened to you off the
field well I have said some things that
have made people uncomfortable I haven't
always been politically correct but in
order to force change you have to be
able to get through adversity some of
the greatest global leaders that I have
met have been able to get through
adversity and found a better way to lead
so yes I've been through some things off
the field but it's only made me a better
leader and
better person so I'm done apologizing
for them I have learned from them and
you know I think it's important that we
all do the same and hope just quickly we
were we first met during the 60 minutes
piece about women on the US soccer team
trying to win equality and pay with the
men's team do they have equal pay yet we
do not there's been a new CBA which is a
new contract between the women's team
and the Federation and it is still not
equal unfortunately the Federation tries
to convolute it to the general public by
saying well it's equitable but it's
what's equitable mean that's the same
thing as equal so really we're still not
there yet and that is another part of my
my platform is gender equality so madam
president has a nice ring to you thank
you